ASSEMBLY MEMBER WAR NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. ARAMBULA OUR QUE
HAN BENEFITS BERMAN BIGELOW
BLOOM ANAHOLA BONTA BRIAN ALONE
ZERO CERVANTES CHEN CHOI COOLEY
COOPER. CUNNINGHAM DALLY DALY
DAVIES FLORA MIKE FONG VINCE
FONG FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN
JONES SAWYER KALRA KILEY LACKEY
LIED LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA.
MULLIN MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN QUINN
O'DONNELL ANDERSON PETRIE-NORRIS
QUIRK BOOKS SILVA RAMOS RAY IS
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
C. A. R. TO SMITH STONE TAKING
HELLO THERE IS THE APPROVED
VOEPEL WALDRON. WORD WEBER WICKS
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS
APPOINTED PRESIDENT FORMS
PRESENCE WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER. AS
PART OF OUR OBSERVANCE OF BLACK
HISTORY MONTH THE DAYS PRAYER
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN IMAM YES YOUR CON. YOU
MONEY IF YOU'RE. IN THE NAME OF
GOD. THE MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST
MERCIFUL. AND WHOSE LAW WE FIND
OUR GUIDANCE. AND WHOSE LOVE WE
FIND OUR HEALING AND JOY. AND IN
WHOSE LOVE WILL BE FINED OUR
PEACE. RULE OVER OUR SPIRITS IN
THIS HOUR. NOW WE WILL GO FROM
THIS WORSHIP WITH THE FREEDOM OF
THOSE WHO TRUST YOU AND NEED TO
HAVE NO ANXIETY FOR THEMSELVES.
EMPOWER US OH GOD TO BE OPEN TO
THE SEASONS OF LIFE. AND GIVE
OUR HEARTS LOVE GENEROUSLY TO
ALL IN NEED. GRANTORS THE
SILENCE OF HEART SO THAT WE CAN
GROW IN YOUR WORK. AS WE ARE
NEARING THE END OF THIS MONTH
FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY TWO WHAT
WE CALL BLACK HISTORY MONTH.
HELP US TO NEVER FORGET OUR
HISTORY. AND INSTILL IN US THE
WILLNGNESS TO SHARE OUR HISTORY
. WITH OUR YOUTH AND OTHERS
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR. I CONCLUDE
WITH THE PRAYER OF DR MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR. GOD GRANT
THAT WE WAGED A STRUGGLE WITH
THE DIGNITY AND DISCIPLINE. MAY
ALL WHO SUFFER OPPRESSION IN
THIS WORLD. REJECT THE SELF
DEFEATING METHOD OF RETALIATORY
VIOLENCE AND CHOOSE THE METHOD
THAT SEEKS TO REDEEM I MEAN.
THANK YOU MAMA. WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US IN THE FLAG
SALUTE PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KEVIN MCCARTY AS HE LEADS
US IN THE PLEDGE. MEMBERS AS WE
RECOGNIZE BLACK HISTORY MONTH
PLEASE JOIN US AS WE DO THE
PLANTS. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA. IT IS. YOU MAY BE
SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL. MISS RARE SUPER
OKAY THE- CONTINUE ASSEMBLY
FAMOUS SACRAMENTO MONDAY
FEBRUARY FOURTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY TO THE CINEMATIC ONE PM
THE AUDIBLE KEVIN MULLIN SPEAKER
PRO TEMPORE IN THE PRESIDING
CHIEF CLERK FOR PART OF THE
DEATHS READING FOR DAVID BILL
MURRAY WILL CALL THE ROLL ONE
CALL THE SIM ASSEMBLY QUIRK WITH
THE COURT OFFICE. MOTION KERRY
TIME ONE FOR THIS EMPLOYED RIGHT
SERGEANT AT ARMS THE DOOR AND
BRING IN THE ABSENT ONE PRESS AT
ONE FOURTEEN PM. MR GALLAGHER
SECOND THAT THE OF THE DAY'S
JOURNAL BE TO IT. PRESENTATIONS
IN BRITISH THERE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
THE WILL BE DEFERRED. PARTS OF
THE WILL BE DEEMED READ AND-
DEEMED ADOPTED MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES
FROM THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. THIS RARE ZERO
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE TO ALLOW SPEAKER
RENDON ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WARD
BOERNER HORVATH MAIENSCHEIN.
WEBER GALLAGHER AND
PETRIE-NORRIS TO SPEAK ON A
GERMAN IN MEMORY TODAY. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
ONE EIGHTEEN EIGHT HELLO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS TO HAVE
HER DAUGHTER SEATED AT HER DESK
TODAY AD FOR A PHOTOGRAPHER TO
BE ON THE FLOOR. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS IN
THE GALLERY TODAY ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY PLEASE
WELCOME MRS REED'S FOURTH GRADE
CLASS FROM HOLY SPIRIT SCHOOL IN
SACRAMENTO STUDENTS WELCOME TO
THE ASSEMBLY. THIS WILL ALSO HAS
OUR NEXT GENERATION WITH US A
VERY SPECIAL GUEST AT HER DESK
LET'S WELCOME HER DAUGHTER ELLIE. MEMBERS WE HAVE MEASURES ON
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING TO TAKE
UP TODAY. MOVING TO BUSINESS ON
THE DAILY FILE. FILE ITEM WANTED
PASSED ENTERTAINED FILE ITEM TO
WILL BE CONTINUED FILE ITEM
THREE PASSED AND THE JEANS. FILE
ITEM FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER FREE OF
US ARE YOU READY TO PROCEED. THE
CLERK WILL READ THE BILL.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE THIRTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THREE OF US RELATIVE TO
INTRODUCE A GIRL TO ENGINEERING
DAY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER US YOU MAY
OPEN THE MEASURE. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I AM
EXCITED TO PRESENT ACR ONE THREE
THREE WHICH RECOGNIZES TODAY AS
INTRODUCE A GIRL TO ENGINEERING
DAY AS PART OF NATIONAL
ENGINEERS WEEK. DESPITE RECENT
PROGRESS WOMEN CONTINUE TO BE
SEVERELY UNDERREPRESENTED IN THE
ENGINEERING FIELDS AS A FEMALE
ENGINEER I KNOW THIS UNDER
REPRESENTATION ALL TOO WELL.
WHEN I WORKED AS AN ELECTRICAL
ENGINEER AFTER GRADUATING FROM
MIT I WAS OFTEN THE ONLY WOMAN
IN THE ROOM AND ALWAYS THE ONLY
WOMAN OF COLOR. THROUGHOUT MY
CAREER I HAVE OFTEN HEARD PEOPLE
SAY THAT YOUNG WOMEN DO NOT
PURSUE PURSUE ENGINEERING
CAREERS BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
INTERESTED IN STEM BUT I KNOW
THAT THAT'S NOT TRUE. AS A
FOUNDER OF A NONPROFIT WITH THE
MISSION TO SPARK INTEREST IN
TECHNOLOGY AND ENGINEERING AMONG
YOUNG GIRLS I CAN TELL YOU THAT
YOUNG WOMEN ARE JUST AS
INTERESTED IN STEM AS YOUNG MEN
. WE SIMPLY NEED TO GIVE THEM
CONTINUOUS EXPOSURE
ENCOURAGEMENT AND THE TOOLS THEY
NEED TO BE SUCCESSFUL AND TAP
INTO THEIR PASSION FOR STEM. AS
A LEADER IN ENGINEERING AND AS A
CHAMPION OF GENDER EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA CAN CONTINUE TO LEAD
THE WAY IN EMPOWERING YOUNG
WOMEN TO PURSUE. PURSUE CAREERS
IN ENGINEERING PLEASE JOIN ME IN
CELEBRATING INTRODUCE A GIRL TO
ENGINEERING DAY AND THEN
RECOGNIZING MY GUESTS IN THE
GALLERY WHO HAVE COME HERE TO
CELEBRATE THIS SPECIAL DAY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND ASKED THAT THE FIRST
WILL BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS
THANK YOU. SEEING NO OTHER
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EVENTS YOU MAY CLOSE ON THE
MEASURE. YEAH I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I HAVE- AND FOR THE
FIRST ROLE TO BE OPEN TO CO
AUTHORS. MEMBERS THE FIRST VOTE
WILL BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS. ALL
THOSE. WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. BOTH
OF THOSE YOU DESIRE TO VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL- OPEN THE ROLE. IT IS
VERY LOW. OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
GO. ALL THOSE MOVIE DESERT OF
THE. THE CARD CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE I SIXTY FOUR KNOWS.
ZERO SIXTY FOUR CO AUTHORS. THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO AVOID VOICE VOTE ON
THE ADOPTION OF THE MEASURE. ALL
THOSE. INVADE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED SAY NO. THAT
MIGHT MAJOR KERRY. AND THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS
WE HAVE GUESTS IN THE GALLERY
PRESENTS TO MARK AND INTRODUCE A
GIRL TO ENGINEERING DAY AN
ENGINEERING WEEK. INDIGO R.
SEVEN ENGINEERS FROM VARIOUS
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE FIRMS TO WORK
IN THE BROAD SPECTRUM OF
ENGINEERING SPECIALTIES THEY
ALSO REPRESENT SEVERAL
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERING TRADE
ORGANIZATIONS ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHO THREE OF US
WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY. MEMBERS
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
OBSERVANCE OF BLACK HISTORY
MONTH. WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
FOR THE PURPOSE OF THIRD READING
. MISTER BRIAN ARE YOU READY TO
PROCEED WITH THIS ITEM. YES. THE
CLERK WILL READ AC EIGHT ONE
FORTY THREE. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE FORTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO BLACK HISTORY MONTH
. MISTER BRIAN YOU MAY OPEN ON
THE MEASURE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS ARRIVED TODAY AS
A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS IN
HONOR OF BLACK HISTORY MONTH AND
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF ACR ONE
FORTY THREE. BLACK HISTORY MONTH
IS AN ANNUAL TRADITION FOR US.
IT WAS STARTED BY DR CARTER G.
WOODSON. THE SECOND BLACK MAN TO
ATTEND HARVARD. HE'S OFTEN
REFERRED TO AS THE FATHER OF
BLACK HISTORY. BORN IN EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE TO FORMALLY AS LAY
PEOPLE WHO WORKED ON THE FAMILY
FARM IN WEST VIRGINIA. AND THE
COAL MINES. AND IT IS NOT HIGH
SCHOOL UNTIL HE WAS TWENTY.
BLACK HISTORY MONTH STARTED IT
STARTED AS NEGRO WEEK. WE'VE
BEEN FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO EXPAND
IT TO THE SHORTEST MONTH OF THE
YEAR. WELL I GUESS IS THAT TIME
OF YEAR WE CELEBRATE OUR
ANCESTORS. LIVING. AND THEN THE
BULBOUS E CELEBRATE OUR
TRAILBLAZERS WE HAVE LIVE
FREDERICK DOUGLASS. BAYARD
RUSTIN. AVA DUVERNAY THURGOOD
MARSHALL PATRICE CULLORS
BASTIAAN ROSA PARKS MICHELLE
OBAMA DR SHIRLEY WEBER FANNIE
LOU HAMER. WE TALK ABOUT HOW FAR
WE'VE COME. HOW MUCH PROGRESS
HAS BEEN MADE. AND IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT. IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
. BUT WHAT'S ALSO IMPORTANT THAT
WOULD BE FROM HUMBLE REFLECTING
EVERY BLACK HISTORY MONTH. WE
REFLECT ON THE LEGACY OF
SLAVERY. THE LEGAL SUBJUGATION
BEATING AND BREAKING A BLACK
BODY. REFLECT ON THE CIVIL WAR
JUNETEENTH. THE BLACK COAT. HERE
IN THIS BODY IT'S IMPORTANT WE
REFLECT. ON THE FACT THAT
DESPITE NOT BEING A SLAVE STATE
. CALIFORNIA HAS ONE OF THE MOST
DRACONIAN FUGITIVE SLAVE LAWS IN
EXISTENCE. AND TO THIS DAY WE
SPEND MORE MONEY INCARCERATING
BLACK PEOPLE THAN NEARLY ANY
OTHER STATE IN THE UNION. WE
CAN'T TURN A COLOR BLIND EYE TO
THE ANTI BLACKNESS. THAT IS
PRODUCING ON HEALTH POPULATION.
THAT IS NEARLY SEVEN TIMES BLACK
OF THE GENERAL POPULATION. BLACK
HISTORY MONTH EVEN JUST THE
CELEBRATION. IT'S A CALL TO
ACTION IT'S A REMINDER THAT THE
POLICIES THAT WE PASS OUT OF
THIS BODY OUR LIVING HISTORY
THAT WILL BE REFLECTED ON. IN
THE FUTURE. I'M GRATEFUL TO
CELEBRATE BLACK HISTORY MONTH.
WITH ALL OF YOU MY FIRST BLACK
HISTORY MONTH IN THIS BODY. AND
HUMBLY ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. ON
ACR ONE FORTY THREE. AND AFTER
THE ROLE BE LEFT OPEN FOR COLON. ANY QUESTION OF EIGHT MEMBERS
. ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. I SAW. YEAH
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
ON BEHALF OF THE LATINO CAUCUS
IN SUPPORT OF A CA ARE ONE FORTY
THREE THE BLACK AND LATINO
COMMUNITIES SHARE A LONG HISTORY
OF JOINT STRUGGLE AND
RESILIENCE. WE HAVE STOOD IN
SOLIDARITY WITH EACH OTHER TO
ACHIEVE PROGRESS IN EDUCATIONAL
ATTAINMENT ECONOMIC ADVANCEMENT
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND MANY
OTHERS ISSUES UNIQUELY IMPACTING
BLACK AND BROWN FAMILIES.
SIMILARLY OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE
GRIEVED TOGETHER HAVING
EXPERIENCED THE HIGHEST RATES OF
COVERT NINETEEN RELATED
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND DEATH. WE
ARE STILL HEALING FROM THE
LOSSES IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND
TOGETHER WE ARE UPLIFTING ONE
ANOTHER TO CREATE A BRIGHTER
MORE JUST FUTURE. IN ADDITION
THIS MONTH WE REFLECT ON THE
INTERSECTION ALITY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. ACCORDING TO A
TWENTY TWENTY ONE P. REPORT
CALIFORNIA IS NOW THE THIRD TOP
STATE OF RESIDENCE FOR AFRO
LATINOS IN THE COUNTRY. WE
CELEBRATE THOSE IN OUR STATE WHO
IDENTIFY AS AFRO LATINO AND
HIGHLIGHT THEIR ACCOMPLISHMENTS
AS WELL. EVERY FEBRUARY WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO RECOGNIZE THE
VAST CONTRIBUTIONS THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY HAS IMPARTED
ON OUR GREAT STATE. AND WE
RECOMMIT OURSELVES TO IMPROVING
OUR COMMUNITIES TOGETHER. ON
BEHALF OF THE LATINO CAUCUS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON THIS RESOLUTION. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I'M VERY PROUD TO RISE
OF THE HEALTH OF THE DPR
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF
ACR. ONE FORTY THREE. WALL ASIAN
AMERICANS HAVE BEEN HERE IN THE
STATES OF. SINCE THE BEGINNING
OF THE GOLD RUSH OVER A HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY YEARS AGO. WE'VE
PRIMARILY BEEN COMING SINCE
IMMIGRATION REOPENED IN THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES. WHILE MANY
ASIAN AMERICANS STOOD ARM IN ARM
WITH AFRICAN AMERICANS DURING.
THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT AND
DURING THE CIVIL RIGHTS STRUGGLE
IN THE FIFTIES IN THE SIXTIES.
REALLY THE BULK OF OUR-
IMMIGRATION GROWTH ABOUT
POPULATION GROWTH HAS REALLY
BEEN AFTERWARDS. AND SO WHILE
WE'VE. EDUCATE MANY OUR
COMMUNITY ABOUT THE BENEFITS
THAT WE ALL GET BECAUSE SO MANY
PEOPLE DIED IN FOUGHT PROTESTERS
DURING THOSE VERY YEARS TO GET
UP TO GET MORE EQUITY. TO GET
MORE OPENNESS TO GET MORE
FAIRNESS WHERE THERE WAS A
HOUSING WITH EDUCATION WITH
THERE'S AN EMPLOYMENT IN EVERY
FACET OF AMERICAN LIFE THAT
TRADITIONALLY. WAS CLOSED. SO ON
THIS DAY THIS IS VERY MUCH MY
HONOR TO RISE. IN RECOGNITION OF
BLACK HISTORY MONTH BECAUSE
BLACK HISTORY IS REALLY AMERICAN
HISTORY IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT WE
HAVE TO HAVE. A SEPARATE MONTH
BECAUSE SO MUCH OF THIS HISTORY
HAS BEEN EXCLUDED. IT IS WHY
WE'VE ALL STAYED HERE LAST
COUPLE YEARS TALKING ABOUT
ETHNIC STUDIES. IMPORTANCE OF
REALLY NERD LEARNING ABOUT OUR
HISTORY. BECAUSE SO MUCH OF IT
IS NOT FOUGHT IN OUR SCHOOLS HOW
MUCH IS NOT TAUGHT IN OUR
UNIVERSITIES. THE STRUGGLES.
THAT WE GOT TO THIS POINT.
BECAUSE A LOT OF PEOPLE LAID
DOWN THEIR LIVES A LOT OF PEOPLE
FALL IN A LOT OF PEOPLE. RISKED
THEIR LIVELIHOODS TO ENSURE.
THAT THE STATE IN THIS COUNTRY.
WITH A BETTER PLACE. WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE ON
ACR. ONE FIFTY EIGHT. OR FORTY
THREE. THANK YOU MISTER TANG
MISSED MENIER AT YOUR DEATH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I
AM VERY PROUD TO RISE ON BEHALF
OF THE LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS
IN SUPPORT OF ACR ONE FORTY
THREE DESIGNATING FEBRUARY AS
BLACK HISTORY MONTH. EVERY DAY
IN FEBRUARY WE ARE THEY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CELEBRATE THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND THE STRUGGLE
OF BLACK AMERICANS WE'RE TRULY
AS HAS BEEN SAID BEFORE THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE TAUGHT
AND APPRECIATED EVERY SINGLE DAY
. UNTIL THOSE STRUGGLES AND
CLEARLY THEY HAVE NOT. AS WE
CONTINUE TO FIGHT TOWARDS A MORE
JUST FUTURE WE HAVE TO DO MORE
TO ENSURE THAT OUR COUNTRY
CONTINUES TO HONOR THE
CONTRIBUTIONS EVERY SINGLE DAY
OF BLACK AMERICANS. NOW WE ALL
KNOW ABOUT THE INFLUENTIAL BLACK
LEADERS AT A PAVE THE WAY
TOWARDS EQUALITY AND JUSTICE
MARTIN LUTHER KING. PRESIDENT
OBAMA AND MANY MANY OTHERS BUT
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO EVERY
SINGLE DAY STRUGGLE PEROT KLAY
AND WORK TOWARDS THE BETTERMENT
OF THEIR COMMUNITY AND ALL OF
AMERICA AND OFTEN THAT STRUGGLE.
AND THAT WORK GOES ON HE DID.
THERE ARE THOSE AFRICAN
AMERICANS WHO HAVE TO FACE THOSE
STRUGGLES EVERY DAY AND
HISTORICALLY AND THIS IS THE
MONTH WHERE THEY ARE CELEBRATED.
BLACK HISTORY MONTH ALLOWS US
THE OPPORTUNITY TO REFLECT ON
OUR COUNTRY'S PAST BUT REMINDS
US THAT WE STILL HAVE SO MUCH
WORK TO DO. NO HISTORICALLY
JEWISH COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN. A
LARGE VOICE AN ALLY IN THE
STRUGGLE FOR INTEGRATION. BOTH
IN HOUSING AND CIVIL RIGHTS AND
PARTICULARLY FOR THE INTEGRATION
OF WORKPLACES AND FOR THE RIGHT
TO ORGANIZE. IN THE LATE
NINETEEN FIFTIES A SMALL CHAU
UNION CALLED LOCAL ELEVEN NINETY
NINE LED BY JEWISH ACTIVISTS
LEON DATE DAVIS WORKED ALONGSIDE
BLACK IMPORTER RICAN HOSPITAL
WORKERS IN NEW YORK AS THEY
STRUGGLE TO ORGANIZE. AND I'LL
TAKE A POINT OF PERSONAL PRIDE
AND MENTIONED MY OWN COUSIN
ARTHUR OSMAN. THE FIRST COUSIN
OF MY GRANDFATHER ROBERT OSMAN.
AND A FAMILY PHOTO WE HAVE OF
HIM THAT'S THAT'S VISIBLE ON THE
INTERNET- MARCHING WITH MARTIN
LUTHER KING AS HE WORKED TO BE
ONE OF THE FIRST UNIONS IN NEW
YORK CITY. GOING WAY BACK IN THE
NINETEEN FIFTIES AND FORTIES TO
INTEGRATE AS JEWS WERE HAVING
THEIR OWN STRUGGLE TO PROTECT
THEIR OWN WORKERS AS RECENT
IMMIGRANTS INTO THE UNITED
STATES. AND THOSE WHO WERE
FLEEING THE HOLOCAUST IN THE
SURVIVORS OF THE HOLOCAUST
FACING THEIR OWN ADVERSITY. THEY
ALSO REACHED OUT TO THEIR BLACK
NEIGHBORS TO SAY WE HAVE A
SHARED STRUGGLE WE HAVE SO MUCH
IN COMMON IN THIS FIGHT. AGAINST
OTHER NESS AND
DISENFRANCHISEMENT AND THEY
WORKED ARM IN ARM WITH BLACK
LEADERS IN THE LABOR MOVEMENT
FOR THE RIGHTS OF ALL WORKERS
AND ALL AMERICANS AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT. MANY OF US IN
THE JEWISH CMMUNITY C. AS A
GREAT SOURCE OF PRIDE AND OF
INSPIRATION. I ALSO WANT TO
CELEBRATE TODAY AND TO
ACKNOWLEDGE. THE VOICES OF THE
BLACK JEWISH COMMUNITY AND AS
THE MOTHER OF A BLACK TO. THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S ESPECIALLY
MEANINGFUL TO ME- AND A SOURCE
AGAIN OF PRIDE FOR SO MANY IN
OUR COMMUNITY TO RECOGNIZE THE
BLACK JEWS IN THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY BOTH HERE IN AMERICA.
AND ABROAD IN ISRAEL AND
ETHIOPIA AND SO MANY PLACES
AROUND THE WORLD. WITHOUT AYE
URGENT AYE VOTE ON ACR ONE FORTY
THREE AND I THINK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM LOS ANGELES FOR BRINGING
THE RESOLUTION FORWARD. THANK
YOU MISS FRIEDMAN THIS WHEREVER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK. GOOD MORNING MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE ON BEHALF OF THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS. AND
IS A PROUD POLL AUTHOR IN
SUPPORT OF ACR ONE FORTY THREE
TO RECOGNIZE FEBRUARY AS BLACK
HISTORY MONTH.
ACK
MONTH IS AN IMPORTANT TIME FOR
US TO ALL REFLECT ON THE RICH
CONTRIBUTIONS BLACK PEOPLE HAVE
MADE IN THE HISTORY OF OUR
NATION. CELEBRATING BLACK
HISTORY MONTH REMINDS US NOT
JUST HOW FAR WE'VE TRAVELED BUT
ALSO HOW FAR WE MUST GO. WE
CANNOT CELEBRATE BLACK HISTORY
MONTH WITHOUT ALSO RECOGNIZING
THEIR RESILIENCE STRENGTH AND
CONTRIBUTIONS A BLACK WOMAN.
BLACK WOMEN HAVE ALWAYS BEEN AT
THE FRONT LINES OF EVERY
MOVEMENT WHETHER IT WAS THE
ABOLITION MOVEMENT CIVIL RIGHTS
SUFFRAGE MOVEMENTS LGBTQ RIGHTS
AND SO MANY MORE. AND YET WE ARE
ALL OFTEN NOT RECOGNIZED FOR OUR
PIVOTAL ROLE. NAMES SUCH AS
SOJOURNER TRUTH IDA B. WELLS
HELLO BAKER AND SHIRLEY CHISHOLM
IMMEDIATELY COME TO MIND. THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO NATIONAL BLACK
HISTORY THEME IS BLACK HEALTH
AND WELLNESS. AND I BELIEVE THIS
THEME IS FITTING TO LIFT UP THE
NAME REBECCA LEE CRUMPLER. AND I
HOPE THAT YOU WILL ALL COME TO
KNOW THIS NAME AND FIGURE. DR
CRUMPLER WAS THE FIRST BLACK
FEMALE PHYSICIAN IN THE UNITED
STATES. OPENING HER PRACTICE IN
BOSTON IN EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR.
DR CUMPLIR PAVE THE WAY FOR SO
MANY BLACK FEMALE PHYSICIANS TO
EXIST TODAY. INCLUDING ME. TODAY
WOMEN REPRESENT 35% F ALL
DOCTORS BUT UNFORTUNATELY BLACK
WOMEN PHYSICIANS STILL ONLY RENT
REPRESENT 223% THIS IS AN
EXAMPLE OF HISTORY HOW HIS
REMINDER OF HOW FAR WE'VE COME
BUT HOW FAR WE MUST STILL GO.
EXPERIENCING BLACK HISTORY EVERY
YEAR REMINDS US THAT HISTORY IS
NOT DEAD OR DISTANT FROM OUR
LIVES. IT IS AS MUCH ABOUT TODAY
AS IT IS THE PAST. I ENCOURAGE
EVERYONE TO TAKE THE TIME TO
READ THE LANGUAGE OF THIS
RESOLUTION. THAT NOT ONLY
DETAILS THE ORIGINS OF BLACK
HISTORY MONTH BUT ALSO DISCUSSES
CALIFORNIA'S BLACK HISTORY AND
THE HISTORY THAT CONTINUES TO BE
MADE. HONORING THE ACHIEVEMENTS
OF HISTORICAL FIGURES OF BLACK
WOMEN SUCH AS DR SHIRLEY WEBER
WHO HAS BECOME OUR STATE'S FIRST
BLACKS SERVING SECRETARY OF
STATE. KAMALA HARRIS OF THE
NATION'S FIRST BLACK WOMAN VICE
PRESIDENT AND SO MANY MORE. AND
ALTHOUGH THERE'S A LOT TO
CELEBRATE. WHEN I LOOK OUT ON
THIS FLOOR MEMBERS. I HAVE TO
SAY THAT I DON'T SEE VERY MANY
FACES THAT LOOK LIKE ME. THERE
ARE ONLY THREE BLACK WOMEN IN
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE.
THREE OUT OF A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THREE. THIS SOBERING
TRUTH IS THAT BLACK WOMEN MUST
CONTINUE TO FIGHT AND SURVIVE
DESPITE MULTIPLE NUMBER OF
OBSTACLES IN OUR WAY.
ENCOUNTERING BOTH RACISM AND
SEXISM WE HAVE THE WORST WORST
BIRTHING OUTCOMES DYING AT RATES
UP TO FIVE TIMES MORE THAN OTHER
FEMALE COUNTERPART. AND DESPITE
A TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN STUDIES
CITING BLACK WOMEN ARE THE MOST
EDUCATED AND BLACK AMERICANS. WE
ARE STILL UNDER REPRESENTED AND
HIGH RANKING AND HIGH WAGE
POSITIONS INCLUDING POLITICAL
OFFICE AND ARE OVER REPRESENTED
IN LOW WAGE JOBS AND UNDER
RESOURCE COMMUNITY. SO LET TODAY
AND THIS MONTH REMINDS YOU THAT
WE AS INDIVIDUALS AND A STATE
HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO ADVANCE
SOUND POLICY AND TAKE ACTION TO
BED TO DO BETTER FOR AND BY OUR
BLACK CONSTITUENTS. I WANT TO
CLOSE MY REMARKS BY QUOTING
LINING BIRCH THE FOUNDING
DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL MUSEUM
OF AFRICAN AMERICAN HISTORY AND
CULTURE. THERE IS NO MORE
POWERFUL FORCE THAN A PEOPLE
STEEPED IN OUR HISTORY. AND
THERE IS NO HIGHER COSTS THAN
HONORING OUR STRUGGLE AND
ANCESTORS BY REMEMBERING. BLACK
HISTORY MONTH IS A TIME TO
CELEBRATE AND REMEMBER THE
FULLNESS OF AFRICAN AMERICAN
HISTORY AND CULTURE. AND THOUGH
IT COULD NOT BE CONTAINED IN ONE
MONTH ALONE I'M ENCOURAGED THAT
THE HEALING OF THIS NATION AND
THE STATE BEGINS THROUGH
EDUCATING OURSELVES AND EACH
OTHER. AND THAT AND FOR THOSE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE AND ACR ONE FORTY
THREE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER. MR LOW
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED BY YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COLLEAGUES.
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF ACR ONE
FORTY THREE. AND HOW FITTING
THAT ONE FORTY THREE. FOR THE
REMEMBER PAGER CODE AND THE
SIGNIFICANCE MEANS I LOVE YOU.
AND IN RECOGNITION OF BLACK
HISTORY MONTH I RISE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LGBT
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS. I THINK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE CULVER CITY
FOR RECOGNIZING MANY LEADERS IN
PARTICULAR MR RUFFIN WHO IS
SAID. ICON IN THE SOCIAL JUSTICE
MOVEMENT SPECIFICALLY LEADING US
IN THE LGBT COMMUNITY. I ONLY
THINK ABOUT THE COALITION THAT
IS REQUIRED OF THE INTERSECTION
MALADY THAT EXISTS WE ALSO
REAFFIRM OUR COMMITMENT TO
RECOGNIZING THAT WITHIN THE LGBT
COMMUNITY IT IS ACTUALLY THAT OF
BLACK TRANS COMMUNITY MEMBERS
THAT ARE MOST VICTIMIZED AND
TARGETED. THE MOST VULNERABLE IN
OUR COMMUNITY. AND THAT IT TAKES
INTENTIONALITY FOR US TO
RECOGNIZE THEM. THE FIND WAYS OF
PARTNERSHIP ALLY SHIP AND THE
STRONGEST WAY NOT BY JUST EMPTY
RHETORIC THE MEETING FULL VALUE
. AND COLLEAGUES YES WE LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE THINK THAT
THESE ISSUES ARE OF THE PAST.
WHEN IN FACT WE KNOW EVEN AND
JUST THIS WEEK AND OTHERSTATES.
MEMBERS OF OUR BLACK COMMUNITY
ARE TARGETED. ASSEMBLY COOLEY
BLACK RANS. FAMILIES AS WELL
AND OTHER STATES JUST THIS WEEK
QUALIFYING GENDER AFFIRMING CARE
AS CHILD ABUSE. AND SO WHAT WE
THINK THAT THIS IS. A THING OF
THE PAST. IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT
WE ADDRESS IT AS A NATIONAL
ISSUE AS WELL. AND SO WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT. HOW WE USE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO REFLECT. WE STAND
IN SOLIDARITY WITH OUR BLACK
COMMUNITY YES AS WE BEGAN EARLY
TODAY BUT THE NOTION OF LOVE
MEMBERS OF OUR LGBT COMMUNITY
WILL CONTINUE TO CRY WITH YOU.
WILL CONTINUE TO MARCH WITH YOU
WILL CONTINUE TO FIGHT WITH YOU
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY COLLEAGUES
WILL CONTINUE TO LIVE WITH YOU.
PLEASE JOIN IN SUPPORTING ACR
ONE FORTY THREE. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW MISTER RAMOS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR DESK
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND I RISE IN SOLIDARITY
WITH OUR BLACK TOP IS-
COLLEAGUES FROM THE NATIVE
AMERICAN LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS WE
STAND IN SOLIDARITY ON A COMMON
THREAD THE COMMON THREAD THAT
HISTORY HAS LOOKED IN INVOLVED
UPON OUR PEOPLE. ARE PEOPLE AS
FAR AS SLAVERY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OUR OUR OUR COMMON
THREAD AS FAR AS INVOKING MAKING
SURE THAT OUR PEOPLE DO MOVE
FORWARD S. N. CAN HEAL FROM THE
HISTORIC DRAMATIST TAKEN PLACE
BUT NO WAY SHOULD THAT TAKE AWAY
FROM THE RESILIENCY OF YOUR
PEOPLE OF OUR PEOPLE TO MAKE
SURE THAT TODAY WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT THESE ISSUES ON THE FLOOR
OF THE STATE LEGISLATURE OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. RECOGNIZING
ALL THOSE THAT HAVE COME FORWARD
AND CONTRIBUTED TO WHERE WE ARE
TODAY WE CONTINUE TO WORK
TOGETHER BUT WE SHOULD NEVER
FORGET ABOUT THE RESILIENCY IN
THE RESISTANCE THE RESISTANCE TO
LET OTHER CULTURES COME IN THAT
WE STAND UNITED TODAY TO MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THE
HISTORY WHAT WE'RE DOING TODAY
AND WHERE WE'RE HEADED. AND THAT
GOES INTO THE EDUCATIONAL
COMPONENTS OF TEACHING EVERYONE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FROM
THE YOUNG AGES TO THE OLD ABOUT
WHAT TRULY HAS HAPPENED
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE OUR NATION
IN HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE STAND IN
SOLIDARITY WE STAND WITH THE
COMMON THREAD FROM THE NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THE DAY THAT WE SEE
MORE FAMILIAR FACES OF NATIVE
AMERICAN PEOPLE A BLACK CAUCUS
MEMBERS IN THE DIVERSITY
CONTINUES TO GROW HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT ALSO IN
THE STATE LEGISLATURE WE STAND
IN SOLIDARITY WE SHARE A COMMON
THREAD AND WE STAND UNITED AND
URGENT I VOTE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA RECOGNIZED THE
CONTRIBUTIONS. THAT THE BLACK
AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE DONE IN THE
BLACK POCKET STANCE FORWARD AND
LET HISTORY MONTH SHOULD NOT
JUST BE MONTH. IT SHOULD BE
EVERY DAY THAT WE WAKE UP AND
GIVE THE HONOR IN THAT
CONTRIBUTION TO THOSE THAT ARE
PAVE THE WAY FOR US TO BE HERE.
WE STAND IN SOLIDARITY IN
HONORING BLACK HISTORY MONTH NOT
JUST THIS MONTH BUT EVERY MONTH
AND EVERY DAY I URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER RAMOS. IS
THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS MEASURE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MISTER BRYANT
YOU MAY CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NOVEL. THANK YOU. ALL THE
BAY HAVING SEIZED WE WILL MOVE
TO VOTE ON THIS MEASURE MISTER
BRIAN ASKED FOR THE ROLE BE OPEN
SO MEMBERS MET AS CO AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROAD.
REVOKE FROM WE HAVE. STRUCTURE.
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE%
THERE ARE SIXTY NINE CO AUTHORS
ADDED WE WILL NOW TAKE A VOTE ON
THE MEASURE WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
CAN TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON ACR ONE
FORTY THREE. ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. ALL THOSE OPPOSED SAY
NAY. THE EYES HAVE IT THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS
NOT YOUR DESK OR MEMENTOS FROM
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS CELEBRATE BLACK HISTORY
MONTH WE HAVE A CLOCK FACE MASK
MADE FROM AFRICENTRIC PRINT THE
SLOGAN ON IT WE ALSO HAVE A BOOK
TAKE A LESSON BLACKETT CHEEVER'S
ON HOW THEY MADE IT AND WHAT
THEY'VE LEARNED ALONG THE WAY.
THE AUTHORS CAROLINE CLARK THE
GRANDDAUGHTER OF THE SINGER
MAKING CALL. THERE'S ALSO A ONE
LOVE TRAFFICANTE THANK YOU FOR
HELPING US MARK THIS CELEBRATION
AND COMMEMORATION OF BLACK
HISTORY MONTH IN OUR STATE AND
OUR NATION. THIS CONCLUDES THE
ASSEMBLY'S OBSERVANCE OF BLACK
HISTORY MONTH THANK YOU.
YOU'RE
NOW GOING ON TO ITEM NUMBER SIX
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON ARE YOU
READY TO PROCEED. THE CLERK WILL
READ THEBILL HOUSE RESOLUTION
EIGHTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON RELATIVE TO S. C. INTO A
NATIONAL AWARENESS DAY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON YOU MAY OPEN ON
THE MEASURE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT H. R.
EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH PLEASED WITH
SIX TO RECOGNIZE TODAY FEBRUARY
TWENTY FOURTH AS THE S. C. N. TO
A NATIONAL AWARENESS DAY. S. C.
IN A TO A IS A IS A GENE MOST
AND MOST COMMONLY ASSOCIATED
WITH EARLY. ANSETT OF EPILEPSY
USERS. AND OTHER OF MOVES
MOVEMENT DISORDERS TODAY MORE
THAN FIVE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
EIGHT AFRICAN AMERICANS ARE
LIVING WITH ACTIVE EPILEPSY IN
THE UNITED STATES. NOT FORGET
AMERICANS ALMOST MOST LIKELY
EXPERIENCING A MEDICAL EMERGENCY
IN WHICH CAESARS CONTINUED FOR
MORE THAN TEN MINUTES. AT A TIME
WITHOUT STOPPING. AND ACCESS TO
APPROPRIATE FEAR IS CENTRAL IN
THE CENTRAL PROBLEM IN THIS AREA
. SO IN RECOGNITION OF BLACK
HISTORY MONTH THE EFFORTS IS TO
ALSO RAISE AWARENESS AROUND
EPILEPSY. IN AFTER BURKE
COMMUNITY THE NEED FOR MORE
RESEARCH ON GENETIC DISORDER AND
ACCESS TO EARLY GENETIC TESTING
IN COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND THE
NEED TO CREATE HEALTH EQUITIES
OVERALL. THIS RESOLUTION ALSO
ENCOURAGED EVERYONE TO WEAR AND
I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE WHO
HAVE CERTAINLY WORN PURPLE BLUE
AND GREEN TODAY TO HELP SPREAD
GLOBAL AWARENESS AND FIND A CURE
FOR THE S. C. IN TWO A. RELATED
THIS WATER. THESE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS HAVE BEEN EXPRESSLY TOUGH
FOR EACH AND EVERYONE OF US
DOING THIS PANDEMIC. AND I'M
SURE THAT WE WILL ALL RECOGNIZE
A REALIZED THAT HEALTH
MAINTENANCE IS VERY IMPORTANT
MOVING FORWARD. BY RAISING
AWARENESS OF THIS DEVASTATING
THIS ORDER. MY HOPE IS THAT WE
UP LIFT EFFORTS TO DISCOVER NEW
TREATMENTS THAT WILL NOT ONLY
SAVE THE LIVES OF PATIENTS. BUT
ALSO HELP TO REDUCE THE
TREMENDOUS BURDEN ON FAMILIES
FACED WITH THIS THIS ORDER. FOR
ME AND FOR THOSE WHO REPRESENT
WHO ARE REPRESENT THE SIXTY
FOURTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT EVERY
LIFE SAVED IS CRITICAL. IN THIS
DAY AND AGE I ALSO WANT TO TAKE
A MOMENT TO RECOGNIZE THOSE WHO
ARE IN THE GALLERY AS GAS AS YOU
PLEASE STAND. AND LET'S GIVE
THOSE WHO SUPPORT THIS EFFORT
AROUND OF APPLAUSE. THEY
REPRESENT THE FAMILIES OF THE S.
C. IN TO A FOUNDATION AND WE
THANK THE MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I VOTE ON. H. R. EIGHTY
EIGHT. SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON
YOU MAY CLOSE THE MEASURE. YEAH. THE CLERK WILL OPEN AROMA.
OKAY MISTER GIBSON IS FOR A CO
AUTHOR ON THIS MAN. THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THEIR OWN. THERE ARE
SEVENTY CO AUTHORS ON THIS
MEASURE. AFTER A QUICK HIS
CLOSER ALL. TO TELL YOU THE VOTE
. THE CLERK WILL NOW OPEN THE
ROLE. WE WILL NOW DO MOSTLY VOTE
ON THIS MEASURE ALL THOSE SAY
AYE. ALL THOSE BECAUSE THEY NAY. I HAVE IT AND THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MISTER GIBSON HAVE
GUESTS IN THE GALLERY TODAY WE
ARE PRINT WHO ARE PRESENT IN
CONJUNCTION WITH S. C. AND TWO
EIGHT NATIONAL AWARENESS DAY
WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY. WE WILL
CONTINUE WITH THE BUSINESS ON
THE DAILY FILE SENATE THIRD
READING FILE ITEM SEVEN IS
PASSED AND RETAIN. FILE ITEM
SEVENTY EIGHT TO TEN ALSO PASS
AND RETAIN. MEMBERS WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO THE SECOND DAY CONSENT
CALENDAR. THERE IS A RESOLUTION
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. BEFORE
WE VOTE WILL MIGHT BE THE FIRST
TAKE UP THE RESOLUTION THAT IS
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ADDING CO AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL READ THE
RESOLUTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE THIRTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THREE OF US
RELATIVE TO ENGINEERS WEEK.
MEMBERS THIS SERVICE FOR COOPER. ALL MEMBERS DESERVE IT THE
THIRD THE CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR
ALL. ALL MEMBERS THE SENATE VOTE
ALL MEMBERS BUT WE DECIDED TO GO. THE CLERK WILL CLOSER ALL.
THERE WILL BE SIXTY SIX CO
AUTHORS ON THIS. MEASURE MOVING
TO A VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR DOES ANY MEMBER WHICH
TO REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE THE CLERK WILL READ
THE SECOND DAY CONSENT CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE THIRTY TWO BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THREE OF US RELATIVE
ENGINEERS WEEK. THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE- MEMBERS VERY VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE YOU DESERVE A. THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TELL YOU TO VOTE. FIVE
SEVENTY NO SINCERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS- TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS
OFF THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS THE QUORUM CALL IS NOT
LIFTED. THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS
ARE GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK THANK
YOU MA'AM MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO ASK THAT
THE ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED IN THE
MEMORY OF FRANCE WE FRANCINE
ANTOINETTE MAY DAY. FRANCINE WAS
A MUCH BELOVED MEMBER OF THE
ASSEMBLY FAMILY AS DISTRICT
DIRECTOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER LORETTA
GONZALEZ FOR EIGHT YEARS SHE
DIED THE NIGHT BEFORE LAST AFTER
SURVIVING THE STAGE FOR LUNG
CANCER SINCE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. SHE HAD NEVER SMOKED
AND WAS JUST FORTY ONE YEARS OLD
. FRANCINE MAY DAY WAS BORN IN
THE PHILIPPINES AND EMIGRATED TO
CALIFORNIA AS A YOUNG CHILD
LIVING IN CHULA VISTA. SHE SAID
HER LAST NAME CAME FROM A
TAGALOG WORD MEANING TO DO
SOMETHING WELL BUT SHE DID MANY
THINGS WELL. SHE DANCED WITH THE
SAN FRANCISCO BALLET. SHE HOW
THE GREASE FROM HARVARD AND
UCLA. SHE WAS A POET. AND SHE
WAS AN ACTIVE LEADER IN THE
FILIPINO COMMUNITY. OF THE MANY
HATS SHE WORE HER MOST CHERISHED
WITH THAT THE DISTRICT DIRECTOR
SERVING IN SERVING THE FAMILIES
IN THE EIGHTIETH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT. SHE WORKED UP TO THE
END AND IN DOING SO ONE MANY
FRIENDS IN THE SAN DIEGO
COMMUNITY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ DESCRIBED HER BY SAYING
SHE WASN'T JUST A GOOD PERSON
SHE WAS THE BEST PERSON. SHE WAS
ADORED AND TO SURVIVE BY HER
PARENTS HER SISTER. HER NIECES
AND A NEPHEW. I ASKED WE
ADJOURNED TODAY IN THE MEMORY OF
FRANCE WITH FRANCINE AND TWIN
THAT MAY DAY. THANK YOU SPEAKER
RENDON ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MISTER SPEAKER THANK YOU FOR
THOSE WORDS- WE ARE DEVASTATED
SAN DIEGO. FRANCINE HELPED OUT
ALL OF OUR DISTRICTS AND SHE-
ENGAGE WITH ALL OF OUR STAFF AND
ALL OF OUR CONSTITUENTS SHE WAS
A MODEL OF SERVICE AND WHAT WE
SEEK FOR ASSEMBLY STAFF AND
PARTICULARLY THOSE. THAT ARE
COMMITTED TO THE THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS THAT NEED HELP ON A
REGULAR BASIS SHE WAS CARING SHE
WAS CRYING SHE WAS COMPASSIONATE
SHE WAS AGGRESSIVE SHE WANTED TO
DO GOOD. AND SHE PASSED OUT ON
AND SHE- WAS A GREAT LEADER FOR
THAT OFFICE AND A MODEL FOR SO
MANY OTHERS IN SAN DIEGO AS
WELL. MR BUT HER SPIRIT LIVES
WITH US AND WE'RE JUST GRATEFUL
FOR ALL THAT SHE GAVE TO THE
ASSEMBLY AND TO OUR CONSTITUENTS
. THANK YOU MISTER OR MS
BURNETTE HER MORE ABOUT THE ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I ALSO RISE TO
ADJOURN THE MEMORY OF FRANCINE.
YOU KNOW IN SAN DIEGO WHERE
CLOSE KNIT COMMUNITY AND WHEN I
GOT ELECTED. YOU KNOW I WAS THE
FIRST DEMOCRAT SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT AND I DON'T KNOW
HOW TO SET UP A DISTRICT OFFICE.
AND FRANCINE STOOD THERE SIDE BY
SIDE WITH MY TEAM AND HELPED US
WIN THE PANDEMIC HEAD AND WE
HAD. THOUSANDS OF EDT BECAUSE WE
WORKED AS A TEAM AND FRANCINE
WAS THE RINGLEADER SHE TOOK
CALLS FROM ALL OVER SAN DIEGO
COUNTY. SPEAKING MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES FOR WHEN WE COULDN'T
HANDLE THE CASELOAD FRANCINE IS
A POET A DANCER. AND A HEARTFELT
MEMBER OF OUR COMMUNITY WHO
EMPOWERED YOUTH TO BE SOMETHING
BETTER TO LIVE LIFE TO ITS
FULLEST. HER MEMORY IS GOING TO
REST WITH ALL OF US HER LEGACY
THAT'S WITH ALL OF US MAY BE
ADJOURNED TODAY IN MEMORY OF
FENCING. THANK YOU MISS BERMAN
HARPER. MR MAIENSCHEIN YOU
RECOGNIZE THAT YOUR DEATH. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND I TO. RISE
TO JOURNAL EVERY FRANCINE SHE
WAS SOMEBODY THAT- I GOT TO KNOW
ON A NUMBER OF OCCASIONS- I
CERTAINLY WAS STRUCK BY HER
ABILITY PERSONALITY. AND THE WAY
SHE REALLY LOVED LIFE VERY
VIBRANT. SOMEBODY WANTED TO
SERVE NOT JUST HER COMMUNITY.
BUT THE COMMUNITY OF SAN DIEGO
WE WORKED ON. SEVERAL EVENTS.
THAT AFFECTED MY DISTRICT MAYBE
EVEN A LITTLE BIT MORE THAN AND
HER OWN BUT SHE JUMPED IN JUST
AS MUCH THEN. I ALSO KNOW HOW
MUCH SHE MEANT. TO BY OUR FORMER
COLLEAGUE MS GONZALEZ- AND HOW
PERSONAL THAT IS FOR HER AS WELL
TO GO THROUGH THIS LOSS. SHE
SOMEBODY THAT WOULD MESS THAT I
THINK YOU CAN SEE BY THE FACT
THAT THE- ALL ALL THE DELEGATION
AND SAN DIEGO STANDS AND SPEAKS
AND HER MEMORY HOW MUCH SHE
MEANT. TO EACH ONE OF US SHE
WILL BE MISSED. THANK YOU MISS
MADE. THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED
MEMBERS WE STILL HAVE
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
REMAINING. PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS
OFF THE FLOOR. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT
YOUR DESK. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY IN SADNESS AS WE- THE
GERMAN IN MEMORY OF MY FRIEND.
AND A BELOVED MEMBER OF OUR
COMMUNITY JOE HENDERSON. JOE
PASSED AWAY PEACEFULLY AT HIS
HOME IN OXFORD ALABAMA ON
JANUARY EIGHTEENTH TWO THOUSAND
AND TWENTY TWO- I GREW UP WITH
JOE. AND HE WAS REALLY AN
AMAZING GUY- AS A KID JOE COULD
DO ANYTHING- HE YOU KNOW I DON'T
KNOW THAT WE CALLED IN THIS BUT
HE WAS GI JOE TO ME- BECAUSE-
YOU KNOW HE COULD RUN THE
FASTEST. HE WAS THE SMARTEST KID
IN THE CLASS GREAT ATHLETE- AND
JUST A LOVABLE PERSONALITY- THAT
ALWAYS KEPT US LAUGHING. NO A
FOURTEEN YEARS OLD JOE GOT
STRUCK THIS GREAT ATHLETE THIS
THIS YOUNG MAN- WAS STRUCK WITH
THE A VIRUS ON AN INFECTION THAT
GREW THE PUT HIM IN THE HOSPITAL
FOR MONTHS. AND WHEN HE CAME OUT
OF IT- IT TOOK A GREAT TOLL ON
HIS ON HIS BODY- AND PHYSICALLY
PARALYZED IN. ONE ONE HALF OF
HIS BODY- AT FOURTEEN YEARS OLD
RIGHT WHEN RIGHT WHEN HE WAS
STARTING TO GET GOING- BUT YOU
WOULD NEVER KNOW IT. BECAUSE FOR
THE REST OF JOE'S LIFE. HE LIVED
IT TO THE FULLEST- AND HE WOULD
HE CONTINUE TO BE SOMEONE WHO IS
JUST FULL OF JOY. AND ALWAYS
JOKING WITH US WHENEVER YOU
WOULD SEE JOE AN EVENT- HE JUST
HAD THIS MAGNETIC MAGNETIC
PERSONALITY- YOU'D WANT TO GO UP
AND TALK TO HIM HE DRAW YOU IN.
I MAKE FUNNY LITTLE BIT- IN A
GOOD WAY IN A WAY THAT YOU
NEEDED IT- BUT HE HE CONTINUE TO
GO ON AND JOE NEVER LET ANYTHING
GET IN HIS WAY- HE CERTAINLY
DIDN'T LET THAT. THAT CHILDHOOD
ILLNESS- DEFINE HIM. THIS HE
CONTINUED TO GO ON AND HE
GRADUATED FROM CSU SACRAMENTO
WE'RE HERE EARNED A DEGREE IN
BUSINESS- HE CONTINUED TO WORK
IN THE COMMUNITY. AS SO AND SO
MANY DIFFERENT WAYS HE WAS A
REALTOR HE WAS A TRACTOR
SALESMEN. HE RAN THE LOCAL FLOOD
CONTROL DISTRICT. AND EVERYTHING
THAT HE DID HE EXCELLED. AND
THEN JOE WENT ON TO GET INTO
POLITICS. OUR OUR ARRIVAL WE
GREW UP IN EAST NICOLAS ARE
RIVAL IS A COMMUNITY CALLED
WHEATLEY. AND JOE ACTUALLY MOVED
TO WHEATLAND BECAME A MEMBER OF
THAT COMMUNITY AND HE BECAME THE
MAYOR. OF WEAKLAND- AND PROBABLY
ONE OF THE MOST BELOVED MARES-
OF THAT CITY. AGAIN THAT THAT
SAME MAGNETIC PERSONALITY MADE
HIM GREAT RETAIL POLITICS- AND
HE HE WON OVER SO MANY. AND HE
WAS HE WAS DEDICATED TO HIS
COMMUNITY HE WAS ALWAYS THERE.
WHEN THERE WAS A NEED. A
CHARITABLE FUNDRAISER. WHATEVER
IT WAS YOU CAN COUNT ON JOE
WOULD SHOW UP AND BE PART OF IT
. HE ENDED UP GETTING HIS CLASS
A TRUCKING LICENSE HE OWNED A
SMALL TRUCKING COMPANY AGAIN
THIS WAS GI JOE THERE WAS
NOTHING HE COULD NOT DO- HE RAN
A BEEKEEPING BUSINESS AS WELL AS
FAMILY. AT A BEEKEEPING BUSINESS
AND HE KEPT THAT GOING- HIS
GREATEST JOY THE- WAS HIS SON J.
W. IN A FEW YEARS BACK HE MOVED
TO ALABAMA SO HE COULD BE CLOSE
TO HIS SON. I KNOW HE JUST
ENJOYED EVERY MOMENT OF. THIS
WAS SADNESS THAT WE'VE LOST HIS
GREAT PERSONALITY MUCH TOO SOON
BUT WE ARE JUST SO BLESSED. BUT
WHAT WE GOT BY THE MANY YEARS WE
DID GET WITH JOE HENDERSON- OUR
COMMUNITY IS GRIEVING BUT HE
TRIPPED LEFT A TREMENDOUS LEGACY
AND WE WILL ALL CONTINUE. TO
REMEMBER HIS JOKES. TO REMEMBER
. HIS LOVE LIFE- AND TO LIVE UP
TO HIS DEDICATION TO OUR
COMMUNITY THANK YOU MEMBERS.
THANK YOU SEVEN MEMBER GALLAGHER
. ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
HERE RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DEATH.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
TO ASK THE ASSEMBLY TO ADJOURN
IN THE MEMORY OF HUNTINGTON
BEACH POLICE OFFICER. NICHOLAS
VELLA. OFFICER BELLO WAS
TRAGICALLY KILLED LAST WEEKEND
AFTER HIS POLICE HELICOPTER H.
B. ONE CRASHED IN THE WATERS OFF
NEWPORT BEACH OFFICER BALLOT WAS
RESPONDING TO A CALL FOR SERVICE
. ANOTHER OFFICER WAS ALSO
SERIOUSLY INJURED IN THE CRASH.
OFFICER FELLOW WITH A FOURTEEN
YEAR VETERAN OF THE DEPARTMENT
AND A DEDICATED FIRST RESPONDER
AND HE LEAVES BEHIND HIS BELOVED
WIFE AND DAUGHTER. PRIOR TO
JOINING HUNTINGTON BEACH POLICE
DEPARTMENT IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
IT WAS A WELL LOVED AND WELL
RESPECTED OFFICER WITH THE
LAGUNA BEACH POLICE DEPARTMENT.
IN HIS FREE TIME OFFICER VALID
SUPPORTED NUMEROUS NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS AND COMMUNITY
GROUPS INCLUDING OPERATION SURF.
BAKER TO VEGAS ADOPTED FREEDOM
FOUNDATION AND HUNTINGTON BEACH
POLICE OFFICERS FOUNDATION.
OFFICER BELLA HAD A TREMENDOUS
IMPACT NOT JUST ON THE COMMUNITY
OF HUNTINGTON BEACH BUT ACROSS
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. IS TRAGIC
LOSS HAS BEEN FELT FAR AND WIDE
AND WE HAVE SEEN A TREMENDOUS
OUTPOURING OF LOVE AND SUPPORT.
ACROSS ORANGE COUNTY AND ACROSS
THE ENTIRE STATE. THIS TRAGEDY
REALLY SERVES AS A POWERFUL
REMINDER TO THE IMMEASURABLE
SACRIFICE THAT OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS EXCEPT IN THE SERVICE
OF THE COMMUNITIES THAT THEY ARE
SWORN TO PROTECT. WE WILL BE
FOREVER GRATEFUL FOR OFFICER
NICHOLAS VALET SERVICE AND HIS
DEDICATION TO THE PEOPLE OF
HUNTINGTON BEACH AND ORANGE
COUNTY. I'D ASK THAT YOU JOIN ME
IN A MOMENT OF SILENCE TO HONOR
OFFICER BALLOT.
THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER. I RISE TODAY
TO ASK THE ASSEMBLY TO JOIN IN
MEMORY OF HUNTING BEACH OFFICER
NICOLAS. BELLA WHO'S ALSO MOST
OF US CALL HIM NICK. RESIDENTS
OF THE CITY OF ANAHEIM OFFICER
BELLA GREW UP IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND SPENT FORTY YEARS
OF HIS LIFE SERVING THE PEOPLE
OF HUNTING BEACH AS A POLICE
OFFICER. HE PASSED AWAY LAST
SUNDAY FROM INJURIES HE SUFFERED
WHEN THE HELICOPTER HE WAS IN
CRASHED IN NEWPORT BEACH.
AUSUBEL N. THE PILOT WERE
RESPONDING TO DISTURBANCE CALL
IN NEIGHBORING NEWPORT BEACH
WHEN SURVEILLANCE VIDEO FROM A
HOME CAPTURE THE HELICOPTER GO
DOWN. IT IS A REMINDER. THE
SACRIFICE THAT OUR PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICERS FACE ON A DAY TO DAY
BASIS. AND THEY ARE ON DUTY TO
PROTECT. THE REST OF US. OUR
COMMUNITY IS DEVASTATED TO SEE
THIS HERO. AND DEDICATED PUBLIC
SERVANT TO GO TOO SOON OF
SEVILLA'S DEATH HAS HIT THE CITY
OF HUNTING BEACH. THE HUNTING
BEACH CITY POLICE DEPARTMENT
EXTREMELY HARD. HIGHLY
SPECIALIZED UNITS LIKE AHREFS
SERVICES ARE KNOWN FOR FOSTERING
A DEEP SENSE OF COMMUNITY AMONG
THEIR MEMBERS. WE ARE INCREDIBLY
WAY FOR THE LOVE AND SACRIFICE
HE HD FOR OUR COMMUNITY OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS AND OUR FAMILIES.
ALSO BILL IS SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE CHRISTI AND THEIR DAUGHTER
HIS FRIENDS AND COLLEAGUES WILL
REMEMBER HIM AS A DEDICATED
PUBLIC SERVANT. A LOVING FATHER
. AND HAS BEEN WE OFFER OUR
PRAYERS AND CONDOLENCES TO HIS
FAMILY THE CITY OF HUNTING BEACH
HUNTED BEACH FACE APARTMENT
LAGUNA BEACH POLICE DEPARTMENT
AND OUR COMMUNITY AND THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY. AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
TURN IN HIS MEMBER TODAY. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHEN DR TORY
ARE RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IN THE
MEMBERS ARE A RISE OF WITH A
VERY SADDENED THE HEART. WITH
THE LOSS OF ALL OFFICER NICHOLAS
OF VALOR. WAS ONLY FORTY FOUR
YEARS OLD. AND THE HEAD DOCTOR
JOB AS OUR IN HOME INHERENT ON
THE DANGER AS A HELICOPTER PILOT
AND THE SERVING THE CITY OF OUR
HUNTINGTON BEACH AND THEN ORANGE
COUNTY THIS IS A SUCH A LOSS OF
FOR THE- NOT ON THE ENTIRE CITY
OF HUNTINGTON BEACH ABOUT THE
FOR THE ORDER ORANGE COUNTY AND
TIE YOUR OUR REGION IS A MORNING
OR HIS LOS. AND WHEN WE A JOHN
TODAY IN HIS CELL MEMORY. I
WORSHIP GOD WOULD DOT COM FOR
TAX IS A FAMILY MEMBERSHIP AND
ALL THE FRIENDS AND THE
COLLEAGUES I ASK YOU ALL OF A.
SUDDEN WILL JOIN TODAY'S SAYS IN
MEMORY OF OFFICER NICHOLAS HELLO
THANK. THANK YOU DOCTOR TO MA'AM
PLEASE BRING THE NAY TO DESK ALL
REQUESTS DURING WILL BE DEEMED
TO AND PRINTED THE JOURNAL.
MOVING ON TO ANNOUNCEMENTS
SESSION IT'S GOOD IS AS FOLLOWS
. FEBRUARY FIFTH. NO FLOOR
SESSION NO CHECK IN SESSION.
MONDAY FEBRUARY TWENTY AT EIGHT
FLOOR SESSION AT ONE PM. ALL
ITEMS REMAINING SHALL BE PASSED
ENTERTAINED ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER BUSINESS I AM READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MR MELINDA MOVES. AND MR CHOICE
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY FEBRUARY
TWENTY EIGHTH AT ONE PM.